apodado como el presidente del ghetto el
músico convertido en político bobby wine
es una de las figuras de la oposición
más relevantes en uganda cuya clásica
boina roja se ha regido como un símbolo
tan potente que el gobierno ha prohibido
a sus ciudadanos vestir las
wine de 38 años saltó a la fama como
estrella del pop en la década del 2000
sus canciones que mezclan ritmos
africanos y el reagge denunciaban la
pobreza y la injusticia social en uganda
en el año 2017 dio el salto a la
política elegido como parlamentario
gracias en gran medida a los votantes
jóvenes en un país donde cerca de la
mitad de su población es menor de 15
años rápidamente se convirtió en un
serio oponente del presidente yoweri
museveni en el poder desde 1986
conocemos a nuestro enemigo conocemos a
los enemigos de uganda y eso es una
vergüenza nacional tanto para museveni
como para su régimen
la campaña de wayne por el cambio y
contra la corrupción ha llevado a muchos
jóvenes ugandeses a estar de su lado
pero también desató la ira de los
poderes fácticos wayne y sus seguidores
han sido repetidamente objetivos de la
violencia y la represión estatal durante
una estancia de dos semanas en la cárcel
en 2018
wayne denunció haber sido torturado
peter qaeda fui golpeado atado esposado
de manos y pies y fui arrojado un
confinamiento militar durante más de 10
días en mente
en noviembre de más de 50 personas
fueron asesinadas en disturbios con la
policía después del que fuera el último
de muchos arrestos para wine en
diciembre cuando se prohibieron los
mítines electorales un miembro de su
seguridad fue asesinado por el ejército
ugandés las autoridades niegan todas las
acusaciones de tortura y arrestos por
motivos políticos inculpando incluso a
la campaña de wayne por no respetar las
restricciones del comité en uganda
su desafío al régimen convirtió agua en
el nuevo icono político para la
población joven del país